الكوليرا هنا في كل مكان وحدهم الاقل حظا
محرومون حتى من الرعايه
والعلاجوا يشربوا منه يا عم يشربوا واسهال
وهذه حالته يعني حمام ما في ما ينضيفه ولا
عندهم قدره انه يشتروا ماء فيديو ما في حل
ثاني
لم يذهب بسام الى المدرسه اليوم
اعادت بعد اكثر من ثلاثه عقودا الكوليرا
الى لبنان واعاده لبنان عهودا الى الوراء
والواحد صعب الهندي
[موسيقى]
هنا بنين مهدي اولي اصابه بالكوليرا في
مخيم اللاجئين السوريين المجاور
عدد الاصابات استدعاء قيام مستشفى
الميداني لكن رقعه انتشار المرض تجاوزت
عكار الى باقي لب لبنان
مستشفى الميداني الذي تم انشائه بتوجيه
مباشره من معالي وزير الصحه الذي جاء
بنفسه ليشرف على تاسيس هذه المستشفى
فبالتالي خففت الكثير من الاعداء عن
المستشفيات المحيطه
الجهود لتامين المعقمات لازاله التلوث عن
مياه الشفه وتامين المحروقات لتشغيل
المحطات التكرير وضخ يعني جديده الانهيار
والفوضى العارمه يتجليان بشكل ماساوي في
هذه المناطق شمال لبنان هنا لمياه شفاء
ولا موارد مائيه نظيفه لاختلاطها بمياه
الصرف الصحي يتشارك فيها اللبنانيون
واللاجئون من سوريين وفلسطينيين واكثر
المزروعات في هذه السهوله ترتوي من مياه
الكوليرا ومنها يقولون رينادويه عكار